-In a time when --
And it´s still an uneasy time
for Obamacare.
But at a time when Obamacare
was under attack,
you were pushing forward
with your
"Medicare for all" proposal.
Some centrist Democrats
were even saying,
"Now is not the time.
You´re going to
scare Republicans
into repealing Obamacare,"
´cause they´re so worried
about what you were doing
with Medicare for all.
Make the argument for why you
can do both at the same time --
protect Obamacare
and push for something else.
-There was not many people
in the United States Congress
who worked harder than I did.
I went all over this country,
held rallies
all over this country
to make certain
that the Republicans
would not get away with throwing
up to 30 million people
off of the health insurance
they have.
Can you imagine that?
People with cancer,
with heart disease,
with diabetes,
with life-threatening illnesses,
and these guys wanted to throw
up the 30 million people
off the health insurance
they had,
and no doubt
many thousands of people a year
would have died as a result.
Fortunately, thank God, we
were able to beat that back.
So I did everything that I could
to protect
the Affordable Care Act.
But what we also,
all of us, understand
is the Affordable Care Act
is not good enough.
We have got to do more.
You have 28 million people
in this country today
who have no health insurance.
You have even more
who are underinsured
with high deductibles,
high co-payments.
We pay the highest prices in the
world for prescription drugs.
One out of five people
can´t even afford
the medicine
their doctors prescribe.
We have got to do more.
We have got to do what
every other country does,
and that is get
private insurance companies
out of health insurance,
guarantee healthcare
to all people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And the best way
that we can do it --
We have a successful
healthcare program.
You know what the most popular
health-insurance program
in America is now?
Take a guess.
-Uh, Medicare.
-Smart guy.
-Uh-huh.
-It is. It´s Medicare.
So if Medicare is working,
if seniors feel good
about Medicare,
why don´t we expand Medicare
to all of our people?
And that is the legislation
that I have introduced
over a four-year period.
We would make sure that
every person in this country
had healthcare as a right.
We would save middle-class
and working-class people
substantial sums of money
by doing that.
-Fantastic. So you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
In your traveling around,
many people consider you
a voice of the working man.
You were -- Back in the day,
before you got this cushy
Senate job, you --
-[ Laughs ]
You were -- You had a carpentry
company here in New York?
-I wouldn´t go that far.
-Okay.
Creative Carpenters.
Is that what it was called?
-Well, we were creative
with the title.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, I don´t know if
I want my carpentry creative.
Yeah.
-I was able to bang nails.
And I did that when I was up --
It was a lot of fun.
I worked for a small contractor
guy who built homes.
It was a lot of fun
banging nails
and putting up roofs
and all that stuff.
-But was that about the height
of your carpentry skills?
-You will not find
my creative carpentry
in your local
fine furniture store.
That I can guarantee you.
-"That´s a chair
Bernie Sanders made.
Don´t sit in it!"
[ Laughter ]
-Don´t laugh.
-Also, I´m happy to hear
that you have been a frugal
person for your entire life.
Is that safe to say?
-Yeah.
-And some old friends of yours
were talking about,
back in the day in Vermont,
that you had --
you would cook over something
that they called Berno.
Will you explain what Berno is?
-Well, it´s a --
I don´t know what even existed.
You know what Sterno is?
-Sterno. Yeah. It´s sort of like
camping food basically.
-Yeah, so this was a variation
of that using toilet paper,
I might say.
Pouring some stuff on it,
we would cook on that.
-So you --
-We have come a long way
since those days.
Why are you taking back --
-I can´t believe the guy
who figured out
how to cook over toilet paper
didn´t make
all that Facebook money.
Thank you so much. It´s always
a pleasures to see you.
Continued good work.
And please come back soon.
-Thanks very much.